[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a uh this is a segment
where viewers viewers try to find
mistakes on our show and we have
terrific viewers that watch the show
very carefully looking for the slightest
mistake so far maybe over 100
challengers no winners
no winners yet because we don't make
mistakes
well tonight a fan named sam baraco
that may be a mistake now that may not
be
his real name no his name is i think sam
baracko and he says that he thinks he
caught a mistake he says it happened
when i was talking about the famous
scene in star wars
where darth vader tells luke he's his
father
conan
i found an error on your show last night
when you uh said
luke i am your father
he actually doesn't say that in star
wars
he says no i am your father
um just wanted to point that out to you
and i think i got you now conan
what
would have killed him to hit mute on the
tv i know
i mean come on what's going on he's
scratching his head the whole time too
he's watching tv yeah
he's like one of my children now
well i'm sorry sam you may think that
you have trapped me but you are dead
wrong darth vader does in fact say luke
i am your father just to be sure i
contacted my good friend george lucas he
personally overnighted his 70 millimeter
inter-positive film print with six-track
magnetic sound so there would be no
question as to its authenticity here is
the scene you're talking about
obi-wan never told you what happened to
your father
he told me you killed me
luke
i
am your father
that's right i said luke
i prefaced my statement by using your
name luke
i didn't want there to be any confusion
about who i was talking to i'm talking
to you luke and i'm revealing that i am
your father
i meaning me darth vader
so to recap
darth vader me has just revealed that he
is the father of luke skywalker that's
you
so tell me some
how do you like them apples
so the challenge still stands if you
think we spotted an error on our show
reported teamcoco.com
i found an error we will sort it out
right here in the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make jump
meat out of the maestro